what jacket was he very he was wearing
jeans and a gray t-shirt I saw him there
that night after the earthquake he
didn't tell me his name and he was just
crying and looked afraid a new glimpse
of hope for Omar and his wife Nisa they
were separated from their nine-year-old
son Radha and when the earthquake and
the tsunami struck since then they've
been looking for him around the clock
not knowing if he's still alive now they
think they caught a break my hopes are
up one of our relatives says he saw my
son with his own eyes wearing a grey
t-shirt and jeans now I feel more
confident that he's still alive hello
and a saying was he they follow the lead
someone saw my child here in the area
around the orphanage he wore grey
t-shirt I think I saw him over there he
was getting water Kumar loses no time
but Rawdon is nowhere to be found
right in day after day of uncertainty in
stifled hopes bernisa it's becoming
harder and harder to take me and my son
were always together wherever I went he
was always with me why did we get
separated that day you have to keep
praying
maybe he got help from someone some of
his friends don't give up I'm sure your
son is still alive Nyssa has posted
pictures of Rawdon on Facebook she went
to the police the Rescue Service the
local radio station so far nothing but
dead ends
this is Ananias national search and
rescue agency and this is where Nisa
came to report her missing son because
on social media was purported that if
people want to find out about the fate
of their family members this is where
they should turn to now we're here to
find out what happened to nieces report
we're shown the missing persons records
not exactly a high-tech database the
helpers priority here is search and
rescue
but they've had some successes so far we
were able to find some 20 people from
these lists who were still alive
unfortunately Rawdon so far is not among
them his name is still on these lists
but Lisa says she knows her son is still
alive it's only a matter of time before
they find him I won't give up I always
think about the time before the
earthquake when we were together all the
time my husband my son and I and I'm
sure it can be like that again
so she and her husband keep on searching
because they know somewhere out there
they'll find their missing son